[Musique]
et je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière avec notre invité la fête du
conte à débarquer dans les médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines pour une
seizième édition
mais annie poquet notre chroniqueuse
juniors nous arrose jour pour nous
parler d'un dispositif un peu
particulier bonjour cas mais alors c'est
une première pour saint quentin en
yvelines pour les habitués vous les avez
peut-être déjà remarqué des petites
tentes ont investi les lieux de lecture
quand on pénètre à l'intérieur on trouve
des livres bien sûr et des petits
coussins pour s'installer tranquillement
ses petites cabanes sont prêtés par la
bibliothèque du chesnay je vais être
garcia bibliothécaire à la médiathèque
anatole france situé à trappes nous en
explique le principe l'idée c'est de
créer un petit coin un peu intime pour
découvrir des histoires donc on a
préparé des petits paniers thématiques
qu'on met à l'entrée de la cabane et les
enfants et pourquoi pas leurs parents
ont plaisir à rentrer dans cette cabane
à découvrir les livres qu'on est à nous
ou à venir avec d'autres livres et
s'installer alors justement derrière
juliette on a pu apercevoir la cabane
elle semble parler de la peur bien
trouvé c'est exactement ça et comme la
masquer la mascotte de cette fête du
compte c'est le loup le thème pour cette
fois était tout trouvé mais il y en a
d'autres en régale nature il ya le
fantastique et même la gourmandise
l'ensemble de la cabane est modifié et
les couleurs changent en fonction du
thème la cabane nature vous n'avez pas
un rideau noir mais un rideau vert avec
des petites feuilles des animaux des
arbres de différents animaux là c'est la
cabane qui fait peur donc on a le look
here chauve souris le fantôme la cabane
gourmandise
on peut imaginer que des choses dont on
se régale et les livres à découvrir sont
également sur ce thème et ce cas balmont
peut y entrer jusqu'à quand on peut les
découvrir jusqu'au 10 décembre
trois médiathèques les proposent à
nathan de france donc à trappes celle du
canal à montigny le bretonneux car
ouvert il ya peu de temps le 16 novembre
et antoine de saint-exupéry intègre péri
à voisins le bretonneux et pourquoi pas
le refaire chez soi on peut choisir un
petit coin dans sa chambre ou dans la
maison dans la maison au moment de
l'accord du paa des parents quand même
temps jamais un drap donné c'est ça peut
servir aussi quelques coussins et puis
le tour est joué
il ne reste plus qu'à se laisser porter
par le comte merci beaucoup à mélanie de
nous avoir présenté ce dispositif les
cabanons le rappelle sont en accès libre
au public mais aux heures d'ouvertures
des médiathèques ne vous faites pas
avoir
on